I'm going to switch gears a little bit and talk less about lymphoma and more about a tool that
can be used to make single-cell DNA sequencing more feasible, much faster, and importantly,
much less expensive. So what is single-cell DNA sequencing? And may someone want to do it in the
first place? As we all know, cancer, and particularly leukemias and lymphomas, are
incredibly heterogeneous. Within a single patient, you can have multiple mutationally driven clones
and subclones, and these change and evolve with therapeutic pressure. Single-cell sequencing
allows you to resolve this clonal heterogeneity on a single-cell level and restore clonal
architecture. So for example, the figure here on the left, this is a fish plot. You've probably
seen these before. Fun fact, they're called fish plots because the person that originally made this
R package thought it looked like a tropical fish. I love that so much. The y-axis is variant allyl
frequency, and the x-axis is time, and each colorful.
Fish, or section, represents a genetically distinct clone or subclone. And for this
particular example patient, you can see some clones, like that red clone and that green clone,
get much smaller on therapy, whereas others, like the blue and the purple, later come back. And
these have different mutational and commutational patterns, and this is important for understanding
what is driving drug resistance. Single-cell DNA sequencing is also important for understanding
tumor phylogeny, or the order in which mutations are acquired. And this is key both for leukemiogenesis,
but also in drug resistance. And Ross Levine's group has used this technology to do some really
beautiful work, as shown in that middle panel. Finally, in recent years, we now have multi-omics,
where single-cell DNA sequencing can be combined directly with either single-cell immunophenotyping
or single-cell RNA sequencing. So now on the single-cell level, we can know the precise
relationship between a cell's genotype and that same cell's immunophenotype. So I could keep going
on and on with examples like this all day long, but so far, I've been able to do a lot of work on this.
So I'm going to go ahead and show you a little bit of this. So I'm going to go ahead and show you a little bit of this.
This is a really fantastic technology. Unfortunately, it's also a very expensive
technology. And off the shelf, you're usually looking at, nowadays, I think it's around $5,000
per sample. And this really came clear to me a couple of years ago when I was asked to do
correlatives for a pediatric trial through COG. And this was a fairly small trial. It was only
32 patients with three serial samples per patient. But very quickly, I was looking at at least $300,000
for just reagents. And by the time we added in sequencing costs and here's the result,
and human labor, it was well over half a million dollars. And that was not the only correlative for
this trial. It was actually putting together that budget that made me realize there has got to be a
better way to think about how we look at this data. So that better way is multiplexing. So on
a very, very high level, what is multiplexing? Multiplexing is when you take individual samples
from different patients, you combine them into one single tube, you run whatever your assay of
doing, and then you use bioinformatics to say, "Okay, this cell belongs to this patient,
this cell belongs to that patient, et cetera, et cetera." There are two broad strokes ways
in which people may try to do this. The most common by far are barcode-based approaches.
This is somewhat akin to flow cytometry, where before you combine the different samples,
you give each one a cell surface tag, and this can either be truly fluorescent or it
can be an antibody tag, and then you combine all the samples together.
This is not great. Minding is sort of notoriously promiscuous and moves around a lot, and I found
this to be not a very high-fidelity system. What actually works a lot better are SNP-based
approaches. We all have very different germline SNPs because we're all different individual
people, and you can use these differences in single nucleotide polymorphisms to your advantage
as a sort of endogenous barcode to decide which cell belongs to which individual.
To connect samples back to their parent, however, you do need to know that individual's germline
SNP profile, which is not always information we have on hand.
I like combining things, so I used both in our novel algorithm, which we called SNaCS,
for single nucleotide and antibody-based cell sorting. On a broad level, SNaCS first uses
these antibodies, which we called hash antibodies, to divide cells up into two different populations,
uses these populations to decide which SNPs are most important for classifying samples
and clusters them, removes multiplets, and then goes back and uses the hash antibodies
to find cells back to their parent sample.
SNaCS is an algorithm, an associated R package, I think it runs pretty smoothly, and also
has a nice data visualization that lets you sort of immediately see how well your multiplexing
worked, and that's shown here on this heat map. I mean, even if you know absolutely nothing
about how the algorithm works, you can kind of look at this heat map and say, "Hey, I
think there's two different patients here." And in fact, this was two samples multiplexed
together.
Again, these bars at the top represent the cell surface antibody-based tags, and you
can see these
somewhat separate cells out into two different populations. But what really helps are actually
the SNPs. In this case, we found six different germline SNPs that defined our cells into
two different populations. And this was done with an off-the-shelf AML panel. In fact,
we didn't enrich for any specific regions, although later we have started adding in SNPs
that are actually used by the FBI to help with identifying parent samples, and those
work really well.
So how well did this work? To figure this out, I used single cell DNA
sequencing experiments on several different AML samples run as singletons, so that's sort
of the status quo, and then used the same samples and combined them with two samples
together, three samples together, four, et cetera, et cetera, all the way up to eight
samples together. I then benchmarked this against other established methods, mainly
borrowed from the single-cell RNA-seq literature. How did it work? I think pretty well. So this
is the heat map here on the left of accuracy. The more yellow a square is, the more accurate.
left column and all the other kind of comparison methods are the other columns. That top row is
two samples multiplexed together, the middle row is three, and the bottom row is four. And as you
can see, accuracy ranged from about 95 to 99% for snacks, which I thought was pretty acceptable.
A question I had was just how far can you go? So in my experiments, just based on the number
of samples I had access to, I went up to eight samples multiplexed together, but could you go
even further? To figure this out, I did several simulations using synthetic data and found that
you can really push up to 10 or even 20 samples before your accuracy stops to drop below 90%.
So this works quite well. What seems to matter far more, the actual number of cells you can load
onto a platform. So for example, I use the Mission BioDNA-Seq platform, which generally lets you get
about 10,000 cells maximum. So you can imagine if you're multiplexing two samples together,
10,000 divided by two, that's 5,000 cells.
10,000 divided by 10 would be 1,000 cells per sample. There probably reaches a limit where you
say this is not enough cells to make this worth it. For me, I found four samples multiplexed
together worked really well. I consistently got accuracy greater than 95%, had 2,000 to 3,000
cells per sample, and importantly, cut a correlative budget at almost two-thirds.
So in conclusion, SNATS is an open-source R package, runs in seconds, and enables scalable,
accurate single-celled DNA analysis. If you have any questions, feel free to reach out to me at
SNATS.org. And if you have any questions, feel free to reach out to me at SNATS.org. And if you
have any questions, feel free to reach out to me at SNATS.org. And if you have any questions, feel free to reach out to me at
SNATS.org. And if you have any questions, feel free to reach out to me at SNATS.org. And if you have
any questions, feel free to reach out to me at SNATS.org. And if you have any questions, feel free to reach out to me at
SNATS.org. And if you have any questions, feel free to reach out to me at SNATS.org. And if you have any
questions, feel free to reach out to me at SNATS.org. And if you have any questions, feel free to reach out to me at
@SNATS.org. Or you can reach out to me at
you